month that's what they're all about long
term
well to keep our country moving we have
to take another step as well
and i know you're all tired of hearing
me during the campaign and since i'm
elected president
talk about it and that's bringing fair
competition
back to the economy that's why today i'm
going to be signing shortly an executive
order promoting
competition to lower price to
lower prices to increase wages and to
take another critical step
toward an economy that works for
everybody the heart of american
capitalism
is a simple idea open and fair
competition that means that if your
companies want to win your business
they have to go out and they have to up
their game
better prices and services new ideas and
products
that competition keeps the economy
moving and keeps it growing
fair competition is why capitalism has
been the world's greatest force of
prosperity and growth
by the same token competitive economy
means companies must do
all they do to do everything they do to
compete
for workers offering higher wages more
flexible hours
better benefits but what we've seen over
the past few decades
is less competition and more
concentration that holds our economy
back
we see it in big agriculture in big tech
and big pharma
list goes on rather than competing
for consumers they are consuming their
competitors
rather than competing for workers
they're finding ways to gain the upper
hand on labor
and too often the government has
actually made it harder
for new companies to break in and
compete
look at what that means for family
budgets
take prescription drugs just a handful
of companies control the market for many
vital medicines
giving them leverage over everyone else
to charge whatever they want
as a result americans pay two and a half
times more for prescription drugs than
in
any other leading country and nearly one
in four americans struggles to afford
the medication
another example hearing aids right now
if you need a hearing aid you can't just
walk into a pharmacy and pick one up
over the counter
you have to get it from a doctor or a
specialist
not only does that make getting hearing
aids inconvenient it makes them
considerably more expensive
and it makes it harder for new companies
to compete innovate
and sell hearing aids at lower prices as
a result
apparent a pair of heat a pair of
hearing aids
can cost thousands of dollars that's a
big reason
why just one in seven americans with
hearing loss
actually use a hearing aid another
example
internet services where more than 65
million americans
live in a place with only one high-speed
internet provider
research shows when you have a limited
internet operation
you pay up to five times more on average
than families and places
with more choices that's what a lack of
competition does
and raises the prices you pay it's not
just
consumers getting hurt big ag is putting
a squeeze on farmers
small and family farms first time
farmers
like veterans coming home and black and
latino and indigenous farmers
they're seeing price hikes for seed
lopsided
contracts shrinking profits and growing
debt
lack of competition hurts workers as
well
in many communities there are only a
handful of employers
left competing for workers think of
company towns across
appalachia and other parts of the
country where one big corporation runs
the show
when corporations have that kind of
leverage over workers
it pushes down average
pushes down advertised wages by up to 17
as competition decreases businesses
don't feel the pressure to innovate
or invest in their workforce that hurts
working families and hurts our economy
all told between rising prices
and lowering wages lack of competition
costs the median
american household five thousand dollars
a year
hello i'm a proud capitalist
i spent most of my career representing a
corporate state of delaware
i know america can't succeed unless
american business succeeds
let me be very clear capitalism without
competition
isn't capitalism it's exploitation
without healthy competition big players
can change
and charge whatever they want
and treat you however they want and for
too many americans that means accepting
a bad deal for things that
can't go you can't go without so
we know we've got a problem a major
problem we also have an incredible
opportunity
we can bring back more competition to
more of the country
helping entrepreneurs and small
businesses get in the game
helping workers get a better deal
helping families
save money every month
good news is we've done it before in the
early 1900s
president teddy roosevelt saw an economy
dominated by giants like standard
jp morgan's railroads he took them on
and he won he gave the little guy
fighting chance
decades later during the great
depression his cousin franklin roosevelt
saw a wave of corporate mergers that
wiped out sec
scores of small businesses crushing
competition and innovation
so he ramped up anti-trust enforcement
eight-fold in just two years
saving families billions in today's
dollars
helping set the course for sustained
economic growth after world war ii
he also called for an economic bill of
rights including quote the right of
every businessman large and small
to trade in an atmosphere of freedom
from unfair competition
and domination by monopolies end of
quote
between them the two roosevelts
established an american tradition
an anti-trust tradition it's how we
ensure that our economy
isn't about people working for
capitalism it's about capitalism working
for people
but over time we've lost the fundamental
american idea that true capitalism
depends on fair and open competition
40 years ago we chose the wrong path
in my view following the misguided
philosophy of people like
robert bork and pull back on enforcing
laws to promote competition
we are now 40 years into the experiment
of letting giant corporations accumulate
more and more power
and wherever what have we gotten from it
less growth
weakened investment fewer small
businesses
too many americans who feel left behind
too many people were
poor than their parents i believe the
experiment failed
we have to get back to an economy that
grows from the bottom up in the middle
out
the executive order i'm soon going to be
signing commits the federal government
to
full and aggressive enforcement or
antitrust laws
no more tolerance for abusive actions by
monopolies
no more bad mergers that lead to mass
layoffs
higher prices fewer options for workers
and consumers alike my executive order
includes
72 specific actions i expect the federal
agencies
and they know this to help restore
competition
so that we have lower prices higher
wages more money more options
and more convenience for the american
people
today i want to focus on three specific
actions
first the fda the food and drug
administration
are going to work with states and tribes
to safely import prescription drugs from
canada that's just one of many actions
in the executive order that will lower
prescription drug prices
second the fda is going to issue rules
so that hearing aids can be sold over
the counter
that's something the last administration
is supposed to have done but didn't do
we're going to get it done after these
rules go into effect
a pair of hearing aids can cost hundreds
of dollars not thousands
and you'll be able to pick them up at
your local drugstore
third we're going to improve competition
for workers
i've talked a lot about non-compete
agreements contracts that say you can't
take another
job in your field even if you get a
better deal
i made a speech i was just reminiscing
with my staff
back in 2018 at the brookings
institution
where i talked about the non-compete
clauses that were just i found to be
absolutely
ridiculous but how prevalent they were
throughout industries at least one in
three businesses
require their workers to sign a
non-compete agreement
these aren't just high paid executives
or scientists also whole secret formulas
for
coca-cola so pepsi can't get their hands
on it
the recent study found one in five
workers without a college education
is subject to non-compete agreements
they're construction workers hotel
workers
disproportionately women and women of
color
think of the 26 year old employee at a
company
she's a star worker but she isn't being
treated right
she's underpaid passed over for
promotions competitor across the street
knows it
wants to bring her into the higher wage
but she can't do it
her company threatens legal action over
a non-complete cost she had to sign in
order to get hired in the first place
she can't afford a lawyer for help she's
locked in
imagine if you're in her shoes you'd
feel powerless
disrespected bullied trapped that's not
right
workers should be free to take a better
job if someone offers it
if your employer wants to keep you he or
she should have to make it worth your
while to stay
that's the kind of competition that
leads to better wages and greater
dignity of work
look i'm not going to go into it now but
i used to
you know there's non-compete clauses or
people running
[Music]
the machines that lay down asphalt
if in fact you uh get offered a job and
you have a
you know you're in arkansas doing it
a lot of specific examples you can't
take a job
in west texas to do it what in the hell
does that have to do with anything no
i'm serious
where there were clauses in mcdonald's
contracts you can't leave burger king to
go to mcdonald's
come on is there a trade secret about
what's inside that
patty no but i'm serious
you i don't know what you do know i
didn't know till five years ago
the incredible number of non-compete
clauses
for ordinary people who are done for one
reason
to keep wages low
period look my executive order calls on
the ftc
to ban or limit non-compete agreements
let workers choose who they want to work
for
i'm also calling an ftc to do away with
certain
occupational licensing requirements you
realize if you want
your braid hair and you move from one
state to another
sometimes you have to do a six-month
apprenticeship even though you've been
in the business for
a long long time tell what's it what's
that all about
military families for example they're
often on the move between states
with each new assignment so you have a
woman in the military or husband's
following or vice versa
guess what if you have if you're
a plumber you have to get a different
license when you move from
delaware to uh to missouri
look it can't be a significant burden
to get a new license in a new home state
that burden can't be around
anymore it takes time and it takes money
it takes a toll on family's income while
you're waiting
we should remove that barrier providing
more mobility more opportunity higher
wages for families on the move
this is something my wife jill has
worked on together with michelle obama
through the joining forces initiative
for the military
we're going to keep that moving we're
going to get it done
in executive order let me close with
this
competition works we know it works
we've seen it work when it exists fair
competition is what made america
the wealthiest most innovative nation in
history
that's why people come here to invent
things and start new businesses
in the competition against china and
other nations of the 21st century
let's show that american democracy and
the american people
can truly out-compete anyone because i
know that just given half a chance
american people never ever ever let
their country down
imagine we give everyone a full and fair
chance
that's what this is all about that's
what i'm about to do
so i'd like to invite the cabinet
members up here
i'd like to uh the attorney general is
here
john donald garland probably
mr secretary you can come up too i've
been watching on television you'll be
really good
gina raimondo also uh pete
bootages and the chair of the fcc uh
leon excuse me lena uh khan
acting chair of the ftc and uh
director of the national economic
council am i leaving anybody out
anyway come on up this may be the first
cabinet meeting we've had
competitions
so
yes
wondering thank you
thank you everyone
well i made it very clear to him that
the united states expects
when a ransomware operation is coming
from his soil even though it's not
not sponsored by the state we expect
them to actually give them enough
information to act on who that is
and secondly that we've set up a million
communications now on a regular basis to
be able to communicate to one another
when each of us thinks something's
happening in another country it affects
the home country and so it went well
you said three weeks ago there would be
consequences will there be start
yes